THIS IS "THE FIVE."
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA DOING
DAMAGE CONTROL FOR HUNTER BIDEN
AFTER HIS SWEETHEART PLEA DEEM
UNRAVELS AND SPECIAL COUNSEL
NAMED.
FIRST OVERSEAS BUSINESS DEALINGS
GETTING ANOTHER LOOK BY DELAWARE
U.S. ATTORNEY DAVID WEISS, THE
NEVER ENDING LEGAL DRAMA
SURROUNDING HUNTER BIDEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS THINKING
THE FIRST SON IS BEING A RAW
DEAL.
>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO STOP
INVESTIGATING A PRIVATE SEN AND
TRYING TO LINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO HUNTER BIDENS CONDUCT.
>> HUNTER DEN IS BEING
SUBJECTED HERE TO A LEVEL OF NOT
ONLY SCRUTINY BUT ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT MOST MERE MORTALS WOULD
NOT.
>> HUNTER BIDEN COULD BE
TERRIBLE.
NEVER MET HIM.
IS BEING TREATED WORSE THAN
ANYONE WOULD BE.
>> THIS IS THE SON OF THE
PRESIDENT.
HE'S NOT A POLITICAL OFFICER AND
DOESN'T BEGIN TO COMPARE TO
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND TO THE
INDICTMENT HERE IN D.C.
>> HUNTER'S ATTORNEYS TRYING TO
SET THE NARRATIVE ON SPECIAL
COUNSEL SAYING NOTHING NEW HERE.
>> NO NEW EVIDENCE TO BE FOUND.
THE EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN
PURSUED BY STAFF AND MEMBERS OF
MEDIA LOCKING FOR CONNECTION HAS
SHOWN IT DOESN'T EXIST.
IF THE MOST PEOPLE CRITICIZING
THE BIDEN FAMILY IS WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CALLS HIS SON EVERY
DAY ON SPEAKERPHONE HE SAYS
HELLO TO THE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
THAT IS NOT AN OFFENSE.
THAT'S A LOVING FATHER.
>> REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS CONTINUE
TO BLAST THE APPOINTMENT OF
DAVID WEISS AS SPECIAL COUNSEL
FOR SETTING UP THE SWEETHEART
DEAL AS THE REASON TO MISTRUST
HIM.
>> THIS IS A JOKE.
ALL MERCK GARLAND DID IS
VALIDATE MANY ARE MAKING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
WEAPONIZEDIZED.
THE FACT I HAVE NO CONFIDENCE
MERRICK GARLAND WOULD DO WHAT HE
DID WITH WEISS.
NOT ONLY DID WEISS DRAG HIS FEET
5 YEARS AND TRY TO NEGOTIATE A
SWEETHEART PLEA DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S SON HE LET THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS RUN OUT.
>> PIRRO, THERE'S ONE OTHER
SOUND I WANT TO PLAY, HUNTER'S
ATTORNEY ABBY LOWELL.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
GOVERNMENT PROSECUTORS ARE
INCOMPETENT?
>> I'M SAYING IT'S ONE OF THREE
POSSIBILITIES.
>> AND THAT IS ONE OF THEM.
>> I DIDN'T USE THAT WORD.
YOU DID.
I SAID THEM CHANGED THEIR
DECISION ON THE FLY STANDING UP
IN COURT.
>> GO AHEAD JUDGE.
>> OKAY.
THE PROSECUTORS CHANGE THEIR
DECISION ON THE FLY STANDING UP
IN COURT.
NOW, IF I GOT IN TROUBLE I WOULD
HIRE ABBY LOWELL.
HAVING SAID THAT IT'S GOT TO
PASS THE SMELL TEST AND DO YOU
REALLY THINK THAT THE
PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO STAND
UP IN COURT ON THE FLY AND SAY,
WE WANT TO GIVE THIS GUY
IMMUNITY THE REST OF HIS LIFE AS
IF THAT WAS SOMETHING THEY
DECIDED TO DO ON THEIR OWN AND
THE DEFENSE WASN'T GOING TO
ACCEPT IT?
I MEAN IT JUST MAKES ABSOLUTELY
NO SENSE.
WHAT THE PROTESTORS CURES DID
WAS THEY GAVE HIM IMMUNITY FOR
EVERYTHING.
SO, WHAT'S THE POINT OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
AND YET WE APPOINT IN GUY OR JOE
BIDEN APPOINTS THIS GUY SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
ABBY LOWELL IS CONVINCED THERE
WILL BE NO NEW EVIDENCE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LOWELL KNOWS
THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE FINDING NEW
BANK ACCOUNTS BUT THE TRUTH IS
THAT AT LEAST DONALD TRUMP WITH
THE MUELLER SPECIAL COUNSEL WENT
OUTSIDE OF THE GOVERNMENT AND IT
INVOLVED HIM.
IT INVOLVED HIM AND THE IDEA OF
HIS BEING A PUTIN PUPPET OR
RUSSIAN ASSET.
JOE BIDEN WOULD NEVER GO OUTSIDE
OF THE GOVERNMENT AND GET A
MUELLER TO INVESTIGATE HIMSELF
AND HIS SON.
SO JOE BIDEN INSISTED ON HAVING
HIS THUMB ON THE SCALE AND AT
LEAST DONALD TRUMP WAS WILLING
TO GO OUTSIDE THE GOVERNMENT BUT
HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT I THINK
IT'S SO DISINGENUOUS FOR PEOPLE
LIKE DAN GOLDMAN TO SAY IT'S A
FISHING EXPEDITION, NO ONE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO DO THIS TO
A LESSEN.
THE TRUTH IT WAS GOLDMAN
ADMITTED BIDEN TALK BUSINESS AND
SAYS IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE JOE
BIDEN IS INVOLVED IN HUNTER'S
BUSINESSES IF ALL HUNTER IS
SAYING I'M TRYING TO DO BUSINESS
WITH A CHINESE CONNECTED OIL
COMPANY, CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
CONNECTED OIL COMPANY.
THE WHOLE THING IS A CHARADE.
NOTHING WILL CHANGE.
IF IF INDEED WEISS HAS THE
ABILITY TO DO WHATEVER HE WANTED
AND DIDN'T NEED SPECIAL COUNSEL
STATUS WHY DOES HE NEED IT NOW?
>> DOESN'T IT SEEM LIKE GARLAND
WAS TRYING TO PUT THE TOOTHPASTE
BACK IN THE TUBE AND SHUT THE
TUBE BEHIND GLASS DOORS AND
THROW AWAY THE KEY?
BECAUSE THAT'S A LOT OF MEDICAL
TALK.
YOU GOT TO CALL SOMEBODY TO SEE
IF THEY CAN OPEN UP THAT KEY AND
THE IDEA IS TO LOCK IT UP SO
THEY CAN'T GET IT PAST THE
ELECTION.
>> COUPLE THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL DAVID WEISS IS A
TRUMP APPOINTEE.
LAST I CHECKED.
>> TECHNICALLY YES.
>> HE WAS APPOINTED BY FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> RECOMMENDED BY THE DEMOCRATS
IN THAT STATE A BLUE STATE.
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IF A
STATE IS CONTROLLED BY
REPUBLICANS A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT
OR TO GET SOMEONE APPOINTED.
>> SO YOU ADMIT IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> HE'S STILL NOT SPECIAL
COUNSEL WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
>> ARE YOU SURE IT'S NICE TO BE
BACK AT THE TABLE?
>> IF I HAD YOUR FACT PATTERN I
WOULD ARGUE THE SAME THING.
HE WAS APPOINTED BY TRUMP.
HE ADMITTED THE DEAL WITH HUNTER
BIDEN IS OFF.
HE SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN HE CAN'T
ASSURE PEOPLE PRESIDENT BIDEN
WASN'T HIMSELF BEING
INVESTIGATED AND FOR THE DEAL HE
BROKERED WITH HUNTER THAT
EVENTUALLY THE COURT WHEN ASKED,
ASKED BOTH SIDES IN COURT
REMEMBER JUDGE YOU AND I KNOW
WHEN ANYONE ENTERS A GUILTY PLEA
THE PURPOSE OF THAT HEARING
BEFORE THAT JUDGE IS TO MAKE THE
JUDGE GET THE DEFENDANT THE
ACCUSED WANTS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
HE OR SHE IS ADMITTING GUILT AND
WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES ARE FOR
DOING THAT.
SO SHE LAID THAT OUT FOR HIM AND
ASKED THE BASIC QUESTION DOES
THIS INSURE HE IS NOT INDICTED
ON ANY OTHER MATTERS?
AND WHEN ASKED THAT QUESTION, IF
IT CAME UP HERE THERE WAS NOT A
MEETING OF THE MINDS BETWEEN
PROSECUTOR OR THE DEFENSE.
NOW ONE COULD ARGUE THEY KNEW
THAT BEFORE THEY WALKED.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY DID.
I KNOW THAT HUNTER BIDEN DOES
NOT HAVE A PLEA DEAL FOR THE GUN
CHARGE OR THE TAX THING THEY
WERE LOOKING INTO FOR THE YEARS
NOR DOES HE HAVE A DEAL FOR ANY
OTHER THING THEY WANTED TO LOOK
INTO.
IT'S OBVIOUS IT COULD IMPLICATE
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
SO I'M NOT SAYING IT DOES.
I'M ONLY SAYING THERE'S A HYPER
REACTION TO THIS BY SOME SOME IN
CONGRESS WHO WANT TO
INVESTIGATE.
THIS THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT.
INVESTIGATING DAVID WEISS THEY
JUST DON'T LIKE HIM IS JUVENILE
ON THEIR PART.
>> YOU WANT TO COMMENT?
>> YOU'RE JUVENILE.
>> CAN YOU TAKE THAT ON TOO.
>> THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH TIME.
FIRST OFF, DISCOUNT WAG THE
WHISTLEBLOWERS ARE TOTALLY FOR
THIS HAPPENING AND IF MARGARET
BRENNAN AND CHUCK TODD AND
EVERYBODY ELSE TO SIT THERE AND
TALK TO ABBY LOWELL AND OTHERS
ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATION AND NOT
SAYING THE WHISTLEBLOWERS HAVE A
DIFFERENT STORY.
DAVID WESLEY SNIPES DIDN'T HAVE
THE POWER TO BE A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE POWER TO MOVE
THE CASE TO LOS ANGELES.
HE SAID SO AND THEY MEMORIALIZED
IT IN THEIR NOTES AND WAITING TO
BE CHALLENGED SO YOU SAY WHAT
MOTIVATION DID THE
WHISTLEBLOWERS HAVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO DESTROY MY
CAREER PREVENT MY PROCEED VENGS
PUT MY BENEFITS ON THE LINE TO
DO THE RIGHT THING SO THEY WENT
OUT AND PUT THEMSELVES ON THE
LINE AND THAT'S THE REASON THIS
IS HAPPENING.
THE QUESTION IS DAVID WEISS
GOING TO START USING THAT
INVESTIGATIVE POWER AND I DON'T
KNOW WHY JUDGE I'M BEING MORE
OPTIMISTIC THAN YOU BUT WHY
WOULDN'T HE START LOOKING INTO
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS DEALS
NOW?
HE HAS THE ABILITY.
HE'S GOT THE POWER.
WHY DID HE ASK ON TUESDAY HAPPEN
GET IT ON FRIDAY?
MY HOPE IS THEY'LL LOOK INTO IT
AND IF HE'S CLEAN, HE'S CLEAN.
>> I'M NOT SAYING HE'S CLEAN.
I'M SAYING THE WYATT APPOINTMENT
DOESN'T UNSETTLE ME.
>> HE'S BEEN THERE FIVE YEARS.
HE'S LETTING THINGS EVAPORATE.
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> IT STINKS.
IF I WERE A SPOKESMAN OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT I WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEFEND THIS.
SEE YOU LATER.
I'M OUTTA HERE.
THE OTHER THING IS JOY REED WHO
SAYS HUNTER BIDEN IS BEING
TREATED WORSE THAN ANYBODY ELSE
AND WE INTERVIEWED GERALD
DESOUZA WHO HAD NO TAX CHARGE
AND DID TEN MONTHS IN PRISON.
>> I WONDER WHO SHE'S COMPARING
HIM TO.
FOR ONCE I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
AGREE WITH HER AND THE MEDIA
IT'S NOT HUNTER.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT HUNTER.
IN TERMS OF FAMILY MEMBERS HE'S
AS SHADY AS THEY COME.
HE MAKES ROGER CLINTON LOOK LIKE
I DON'T KNOW, ROGER EBERT.
HE'S A FIRST LEVEL BONAFIDE DIRT
BAG.
WHAT IF WE HAVE IT BACKWARDS?
IT'S NOT THAT HUNTER HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR JOE.
IT'S JOE WHO IS A BURDEN TO
HUNTER WHO IS FORCING HIM TO
MAKE IT RAIN, WHO IS MAKING SURE
HE GOES TO THESE COUNTRIES TO
SET UP BOGUS COMPANIES AND FLY
ALL OVER.
IF YOU HAVE REAL CONCERN FOR
YOUR SON WHO IS A TERRIBLE DRUG
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY, WHY ARE
YOU FORCING HIM TO GO TO
BUSINESS MEETINGS THAT'S THE
OPPOSITE THING WOULD YOU DO IF
YOU WERE A LOVING FATHER.
YOU WOULD TELL HIM YOU'RE NOT
GOING ANYWHERE ELSE.
YOU NEED TO TAKE A BREAK.
SO WE WERE WATCHING THE REVERSAL
OF TRUTH AND THEY'RE MAKING
HUNTING THE CROOKED OUT OF
CONTROL SON THAT TESTS THE LOVE
OF HIS FATHER EVERY DAY WHEN
IT'S ACTUALLY JOE THAT'S FORCING
HUNTER TO GO OUT AND MAKE THE
MONEY SO JOE LIVES THE
COMFORTABLE LIFESTYLE HE'S NEVER
BEEN ABLE TO FOORD AND I THINK
HUNTER DIDN'T MIND IT UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT HUNTER WASN'T
GOING TO BE IN OFFICE AFTER 2016
AND HE'S MAKING THESE DEALS AND
JOE IS BACK AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE'S NOT PREPARED FOR.
THIS THIS IS TOTALLY UNFAIR,
DAD.
I WANT TO STILL DO COKE AND NOW
I GOT TO DO IT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> HE DID MOST OF HIS BUSINESS
DEALS WHEN HE WAS LAME DUCK.
HE PUT IT ON HYPER SPEED GOING
TO UKRAINE AS A LA